video with races language surface so
shocking or alleged hazing and now
students could be Vulcan and criminal
charge allegedly creating a secret
Facebook page
I was absolutely not surprised at
English it's the same stuff different
day the only thing I was surprised about
is that they actually con it the racial
problems that we see in these videos are
a problem across campuses universities
throughout the country they get
exacerbated in Greek life because of the
structure of how street life withers
minimal accountability it is a question
of whether the chapter believes in good
values or is willing to let bad things
happen and that's not a systemic thing
that's that's a chapter-by-chapter basis
the biggest issue is just the persistent
denial that racism is even ash and in
many respects especially with political
correctness all that it does is drive
racism underground I think it's training
that will prevent future problems
individual programs individual
initiatives by themselves don't work
that we can actually coordinate them in
an evil way that they actually can't
have a larger more systems level impact
I think the bigger question right now is
asking where is the will to do that
you